hey everybody we're really excited to be
showing off the brand new halo 2
anniversary mappe reveal sanctuary I'm
Bravo with me as Alex Golden Boy Mendes
we're also joined by some of the best
professional halo players in the world
walshy strong side flame sword and
pistol I'm really excited to show off
sanctuary for the first time Alex it's a
classic halo man yeah it's a map that
old-school Halo fans absolutely love and
luckily we have four incredible players
here to show off the map so what we're
gonna do take these four guys split them
up into two teams have them play a quick
match 25 and see what happens all right
let's hop into the match teams for the
match or any wall she and strong side
going up against pistola and flame sword
and we're starting things off here with
flames towards point of view as he
pushes down to the middle of the map now
remember Bravo one thing you want to do
is deny the enemy team possession of the
rockets off the break so flame sword did
a great job of that but jumping over the
strong side here who has a sniper rifle
he's gonna miss two shots sending 18
forward can't quite find the other one
as well but there is gonna be a player
pushing ring one it looks like that's
flames for who snuck ring one's gonna
try to grab that rocket launcher
actually does steal the rocket launcher
misses the first rocket on strong side
and pushes him back yeah man Oh tried to
go for the quick scope there couldn't
quite find it but jumping back the flame
sword now who actually has the Rockets
he wasted two before finds one there
that's gonna make it 120 for the double
oh and he's able to get it making a
score two to one and now switching gears
over to strong side who's off the
respawn just over a minute left and as
you said his team is down by one
immediately pushing towards the middle
of the map I like what he's doing here
with this ring three vantage point I
couldn't agree more with you Bravo
here's gonna find one player down the
bottom perfect nade placement able to
take him out and any line up the double
kill yes he can't make it 3-2 two red
team in the lead and now switching over
to pasola one minute left on the clock
but his team is down by one kill so he
wants to slow things down just a bit he
needs to coordinate an attack with flame
sword as they're forced towards the
middle of the map putting some shots
down on Wall she but does get site for
the right side that's gonna force him to
drop down let's switch over to strong
side who has a sniper rifle yeah and
with that said he has the game in his
hands as well 3 2 2 is the score let's
see what strong side in wall she can do
have controlled the center of the map
there is going to be a player though
ring to finding ones who swift body
shots and that's gonna make it four to
three strong side can shut the game down
already in the no scope for the wind
game over incredible game with a great
nose go from strong side to end it
ladies and gentlemen that was sanctuary